hey Pat what's up Ryoga I mean crisis
mode right now my boss is asking a minor
I don't know what to do okay slow down
and don't worry in the next few minutes
we will lay out the five easy steps to
kick-start your Google cloud migration
journey wow that would be awesome thanks
so much
okay Pat hang on the line and you out
stay tuned
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Priyanka and welcome to
cloud migration 101 where we will talk
about all things migration in this first
episode I'll show you how to get started
with your migration journey to Google
cloud what is called migration anyway it
typically refers to moving apps deployed
on-premise ease into the cloud mainly to
leverage the benefits of cloud like
reduced cost increased security
flexibility and speed it could also mean
moving workloads from one cloud to
another any type of moving can be a
challenge putting things in write boxes
what if something gets lost or breaks
can you put it all back together well
cloud migration is no different even for
the most experienced teams so you need
to plan and execute your migration very
carefully where do we get started
well the first step in the migration
journey to Google cloud town is to
define your starting point now starting
point could be on-premises where you
manage the entire infrastructure and the
apps it could be in private hosting
environment where you manage the
virtualization and resources and the
rest is managed by the service provider
or it could be in another cloud now that
we have defined the starting and the end
points we are ready to jump into stop
number 2 the types of workloads to
migrate this is important because it
helps us assess the complexity of the
migration there can be different kinds
of workloads but for our purposes today
it is safe to categorize them as legacy
workloads and cloud native workloads
legacy workloads are developed without
any consideration for cloud environment
so it can be difficult and frankly
expensive to modify them to run on cloud
on the other hand cloud native workloads
are natively scalable portable available
and secure so consider the type of
workload you're dealing with while
planning a migration now we are at stop
3 it's time to pick the type of
migration that makes sense
there's lift and shift where you move
workloads from a source to a target
environment with minor or no
modifications this is ideal when a
workload can operate as is in the target
environment or when there's little or no
business need for change it also
requires the least amount of time and
are easiest to accomplish
the disadvantages you have a non cloud
native workload running in Google cloud
now which is not ideal to take full
advantage of cloud platform features
like horizontal scaling pricing and
managed services the second type of
migration is improve and move in which
you modernize the workload while
migrating it to take advantage of cloud
native capabilities this may take longer
than the lift and shift because you're
refactoring but it turns out to be
better in the long run because you gain
access to many of the cloud native
benefits the third type is rip and
replace migration where you decommission
an existing app and completely redesign
and rewrite it as a cloud native app you
would do this if your current app is too
expensive to migrate or you don't want
to maintain it this will obviously take
a lot longer but the upside is this
migration sets you up to take full
advantage of those amazing cloud
features including the horizontal
scaling managed services and high
availability
once you decide which migration type
makes sense for your business workload
we move on to the fourth stop on our
migration journey assess your readiness
for cloud your readiness depends on four
themes learning programs leadership
support experience to scale cloud native
services and the capacity to protect
your current environment for each theme
you should be in one of the three phases
tactical strategic or transformational
since this is an exercise that highly
depends on your organization's maturity
for adopting cloud technologies click
here to learn how to evaluate your
organization on the cloud maturity scale
stock 5 on our journey is to define the
core of the migration the migration path
it has four phases you assess you plan
you deploy and then you optimize got it
now let me let me try that again a
little bit slower in the assess phase
you perform a thorough assessment and
discovery of your existing environment
to understand your app inventory
identify any dependencies and
requirements perform total cost of
ownership calculations and establish app
performance benchmarks in the plan phase
you create the basic cloud
infrastructure for your apps and plan
how you will move them this planning
includes creating an organization
folders environments projects resources
and networks along with access controls
sorting the apps and developing a
prioritized migration strategy in deploy
phase you design implement and execute
deployment processes to move workloads
to Google Cloud and in the optimized
space you begin to take full advantage
of cloud native technologies such as
performance scalability disaster
recovery cost training as well as
opening the doors to machine learning
and artificial intelligence integrations
for your apps here is the summary of
five steps we defined to kickstart your
migration journey to Google Cloud first
you define the starting point and end
point which is Google Cloud then you
define your workloads followed by the
migration types then using the cloud
adoption framework assess your readiness
for your cloud journey and finally get
set for the migration path assess plant
deploy and optimize now that we have a
starting point
Pat is off building their migration plan
to Google Cloud you all stay tuned for
the next episode where we will help you
choose what to migrate first if you've
got thoughts on different methods you've
used leave a comment below so we can
continue our conversation until then
like subscribe to keep learning about
cloud migration
oh and check out the more detailed
getting started guide by our Solutions
Architect Marko fire